foreign
[Music]
and I'm an assistant professor at the
department of human genetics at Rockwell
UMC in nightmare in the Netherlands
and tonight I'm going to tell you about
non-coding aberrations in mismatch
repair genes that underlies substantial
part of the missing heritability in
Lynch syndrome
by the end of this talk you will have
learned what the diagnostic route for
the detection of lint syndrome in
individuals with mismatch repair
deficient colorectal and endometrial
cancer is
you will know about the application of
short and long read sequencing
approaches to detect pathogenic variants
in mismatch repair genes and how you can
use functional essays such as mini Gene
essays to assess the pathogenicity of
non-coding aberrations and their effect
on splicing in the mismatch repair genes
in my talk I will address Lynn syndrome
which is one of the most common genetic
risk syndromes
and I will walk you through the Quest
for finding the missing heritability in
Lynch syndrome because our old mismatch
repair deficient tumors initiated by
germline pathogenic variants
or can we find non-coding aberrations in
mismatched repair genes
I'll end my talk with a summary and a
short a future perspectives on what I
think what the next step should be
but let me start by explaining you the
genes that are involved in hereditary
colorectal cancer and polyposis
syndromes
I've been showing this graph already for
about a decade and we know in general
that about 25 to 30 percent of
colorectal cancer cases are probably due
to a genetic predisposition
there are about 16 genes now known and
all of them cause high penetrant forms
of hereditary colorectal cancer
however we also think that there's still
undiscovered hereditary causes and you
may find them in familials in which
there is a strong aggregation of
colorectal cancer and polyposis but also
sometimes in very isolated cases for
instance colorectal cancer at a very
young age without a clear family history
in my talk I will focus on Lynch
syndrome which is caused by germline
pathogenic variants in the genes mlh1
msh2 msh6 pms2 and app game
these genes have already been discovered
about 20 25 years ago
by basically
a very targeted sequencing in the
pre-ngs era so in the pre-next
generation sequencing era
more recently in 2009 epcam was added to
the genes that cause Lynn syndrome
and
um
all of them cause a non-polyposis form
of colorectal cancer
so in particular what is Lynn syndrome
so it's one of the most common forms of
genetic tumor risk syndromes and it's
caused by these germline pathogenic
variants in the mismetric bare genes
when an individual has such a germline
pathogenic variant they have a high risk
to develop colorectal cancer about 50 to
70 percent of individuals will develop a
colorectal cancer or multiple
during life
women have a higher risk to develop
endometrial cancer approximately 40 to
60 percent of the women will develop an
endometrial cancer
but we also know that there's a higher
risk to develop extracolonic cancers for
instance in the bladder
and in the stomach
usually these cancers also develop at a
younger age of onset especially before
the age of 70 years so basically before
the cancers that develop that we call
sporadic
so the mismatch repair genes are
involved in a mismatch repair machinery
and they repair basically mismatches in
our DNA so DNA polymerase synthesize the
DNA and this is not always perfect and
then the mismatch repair complex comes
into action so they repair DNA
mismatches either single nucleotide
variants or they repair
um
nucleotides that have been wrongfully
inserted in mononucleotide repeats or if
a
base pair has not been inserted in a
mononucleotide repeat
so when the mismatch repair complex is
active these are repaired and you will
have stable micro satellites
however if the mismatch repair Machinery
is not active these mismatches in the
DNA are not repaired and also in
microsatellites these will be either
shortened or longer and this will result
in microsatellite instability
the accumulation of both single
nucleoside variants and this instability
at microsatellites It's usually the
first step in the tumerogenesis it
inactivates tumor suppressor genes and
it may activate oncogenes
and this is also what is used in the
Diagnostics of Lynch syndrome in
particular this microsatellite
instability and the absence of proteins
in the mismature bear machinery
I'm going to walk you through the
current diagnostic route for the
detection of Lynch syndrome as we
nowadays use it in the Netherlands
in principle if a colorectal cancer or
endometrial cancer
developed before the age of 70 years in
an individual the pathologist requests
an immunohistochemistry of the mismatch
repair proteins
if the immunohistochemistry is normal
meaning there is expression of all four
mismatched repair proteins it is very
likely that the colorectal or
endometrial cancer developed sporadic
or there's an involvement of an other
genetics humerus syndrome
however in the absence of one or more of
these mismets repair proteins Lin
syndrome is one of the syndromes that is
considerated
foreign
deficient we will have a look at
promoter hypermethylation because if the
promoter is hypermethylated in the tumor
we usually also think it's a sporadic
tumor that has developed or there's
involvement of another genetic tumor
risk syndrome
in case the mlh1 promoter is not
hypermethylated these tumors are also
eligible for germline testing of
pathogenic variants in the mismetric
bear genes
like is the case if msh2 msh6 or pms2
are absent
at that time after genetic counseling
a tumor sorry a germline test is is
offered to the patient and we will test
for germline pathogenic variants in this
mismatch repair genes
usually we only look at the coding
regions of these genes and if a germline
pathogenic variant is identified the
patient is diagnosed with Lynch syndrome
this is approximately the case in 55 of
the individuals that are referred for
genetic testing
meaning that in over 45 percent of these
cases we do not find a germline
pathogenic variant in one of the
mismatch repair genes these are called
The Unexplained mismatch repair
deficient cases or also known as lens
like in literature
these lynch-like cases or individuals
that have an unexplained mismatch repair
deficient tumor are a puzzle for
clinicians because we do not know what
their cancer risk is what should be the
surveillance to offer how often should
individuals undergo a colonoscopy what
is the risk for their family members can
we offer them any
surveillance for the future
this this is a big puzzle for clinicians
we do know that two somatic inactivating
events can also cause mismatch repair
deficiency meaning that in somatic
tissues the mismatch repair genes are
inactivated and therefore causing
microsatellite instability and thus also
asporatic cancer
while we already know this for about
eight years it was until recently not
known how often this occurs
so a very talented PhD student in the
group Lisa Elsa she hypothesized that
somatic non-epigenetic mismatch repair
Gene aberrations underlie most
mismatched repair deficient or as we
call them lynch-like tumors
she analyzed both germline and the
somatic coding aberrations in the
mismatch repair genes in two different
cohorts
the first cohort was composed of 306
individuals in which the mlh1 promoter
hypermethylation was excluded
after analysis of the germline DNA from
for mismetric Belgian aberrations she
identified that in approximately half of
them a germline pathogenic variant was
found
for the remaining part of this cohort
125 tumors were available to perform
somatic coding analysis of the mismetric
bear genes
in a second cohort which was already
pre-screened for mlh1 promoter
hypermethylation
and for germline pathogenic variants and
in both cases this was excluded
123 tumors were available
also to perform somatic analysis of the
mismatched repair genes
so what we normally do is we capture the
mismatch repair genes using single
molecule inversion probes
and we perform Next Generation short
read sequencing of the genomic DNA
extracted from both normal and from
tumor tissues
and we look at pathogenic variants that
occur in the tumor that are absent for
instance from the normal tissue
what she found was that basically the
majority of unexplained mismatch repair
deficient tumors have two somatic
mismatch repair mutations
as you can see in the figure in both
cohorts
we find a
over 80 percent of the tumors that have
two somatic events in a mismetric
Beijing
this seems to be a bit higher for mlh1
than for msh6 and pms2 but on average
87.3 percent of unexplained mismatch
repair deficient tumors presented with
this somatic mismatch repair deficiency
in addition in this cohort we looked at
the age of diagnosis of these patients
and it seems that individuals that have
a somatic mismatch repair deficiency
have a higher aged diagnosis compared to
those that have Lynn syndrome
as you can appreciate from this picture
individuals with Lynn syndrome are
usually below 50 years of age whereas
individuals that have a mismatched
somatic mismatch repair deficiency this
increases with the age
so once the germline pathogenic testing
of the mismetric bear genes was negative
if after that you perform somatic
testing of these mismatch repair genes
we can explain in over 85 percent of
them the cause of their mismature bear
deficiency
basically by two somaticates in one of
these genes
this still leaves a group of unexplained
mismatch repair deficient cases this is
a bit less than 15 percent
they either have one or no somaticates
in the mismetric Beijing and there's
also an abscess of pathogenic variants
in the germline
still again the same questions
um are valid so what is their risk for
cancer what surveying should we offer
them and what about their family members
and although less than 15 seems like a
very small percentage
it does have a big impact
several of these families basically look
like this
so they have an unexplained mismatch
repair deficiency but they developed
cancer at a very young age for instance
the index case in this pedigree was 33
years old when he developed a colorectal
cancer his mother developed colorectal
cancer at the age of 47 and an
endometrial cancer at the age of 50 and
also multiple family members were
diagnosed with the same tumor types at a
very young age
all of them showed microsatellite
instability
and loss of Mitch Mass repair proteins
however thus far we could not pinpoint
what the reason for this mismatch repair
deficiency was
so therefore another very talented PhD
student in the group Elizabeth
hypothesized that non-coding aberrations
in mismatch repair genes underlie this
form of lynch-like syndrome
and she started with the design of
targeted long-read sequencing of the MMR
genes
so again I depict here a gene and the
regions that we normally sequence when
we perform short read sequencing so only
the coding parts of each gene
and she designed long range PCR
amplicons that cover basically the
entire coding and non-coding parts of
the mismatch repair genes including
epcap
so what does this look like
when you perform these um
long-range PCR products we also take
into account the introns
in which we think that we can identify
structural variation
or single nucleotide variants that lay
deep intronic but we can also
discriminate between variants that are
present in the pseudogene instead of in
in the targeted Gene in which we want to
identify the pathogenic variants
to give you the first example she
designed multiple amplicons to cover
both epcam and msh2 with overlapping
segments of about 100 KB
the smallest fragment for this for these
two genes was approximately 10 KB in
size whereas the biggest fragment was
close to 18 KB in size
we also designed these amplicons
for msh-6 mlh1 and pms2
and for bms2 we particularly took into
account all the different pseudo genes
and that we would reduce the chance of
also amplifying in these long-range pcrs
any pseudogenes
so we designed long-range amplicons with
a 1kb overlap
followed by long-range PCR with
optimized protocols to amplify each of
these amplicons
subsequently We performed equimolar
pooling of these amplicons and we
performed circular consensus sequencing
on a pack bios equal to
after sequencing
um and consensus uh calling We performed
mapping of these High Fidelity reads and
variant calling
we also performed this on some positive
control samples so meaning previously
identified pathogenic variants and in
this example I show you some of the
positive controls for pms2
in the upper graph you can see pms2 and
the entire Locus that is covered by our
long breeds uh
sequencing
in the red box you can identify reads
that span Axon 14.
they are
um
[Music]
approximately over 1500 bases in size
in the bottom left you can see a single
nucleotide variant that was identified
and in the middle you can see a more
complex variant a Del in of multiple
nucleotides
then on the right again two deletions
spanning axon 14 whereas we always
thought that this was would be the same
deletion we observed in two different
samples two different deletions and we
now also can perform accurate deletion
mapping of larger deletions
foreign
so back to our study We performed these
targeted long read sequencing on
multiple individuals individuals with
links-like syndrome
we were able to collect 32 individuals
that developed a mismatch repair
deficient colorectal or endometrial
cancer
no mlh1 hypermethylation was identified
and no coding germline pathogenic
variants were observed
and somatic testing revealed only one or
no somatic events
We performed our long range pcrs and
performed long read sequencing
and after mapping and variant calling We
performed subsequent filtering to
identify any potential pathogenic
variants
because we're looking for germline
variants we only select those variants
with a variant allele frequency of over
20 percent
and we remove any variants that are more
than 0.1 percent that have a frequency
of more than 0.1 percent in public
databases such as exac and nomads
furthermore we make the Discrimination
between variants that lay in the exomes
and non-coding variants
and specifically for non-coding variants
we set the threshold a bit higher for
the variant allele frequency to
circumvent any slippage in um in
homopolymer sites
every variant was assessed for potential
effect on splicing using splice Ai and
all variants that remained were visually
inspected using the integrative genome
viewer
this resulted in a potential pathogenic
variant in nine out of these 32 cases
deep intronic invariants were identified
in five cases
and in four cases we identified
structural variants of multiple bases
and subsequently We performed cost
aggregation analysis in families where
this was possible
and we performed functional testing
this is the overview of the various
variants that we identified
in these individuals on the left you see
that we identified variants in msh2 mlh1
and pms2
in some individuals we identified two
deep intronic variants
either these were single nucleoside
variants or in individuals we identified
the insertion of an aloe repeat of over
350 base pairs and single nucleotide
variants
then there was a case in which there was
only an aloe insertion
in mlh1 we identified a case in which
there was a large intronic deletion
also single nucleotide variants and in
pms2 we identified the same
single nucleotide variant in two
individual cases
so what can be the consequence of a deep
intronic donor site introduction
here I show the example of one of the
deep intronic variants that we
identified in mlh2
and using in silico prediction tools
we noticed that this a to G change
activates a cryptic acceptor site
approximately 190 bases Upstream
by activation of this cryptic acceptor
sites we predicted that there would be a
pseudo axon included in the transcript
of msh2
interestingly for us from both the index
case in which we identify these variants
into family members we were able to
gather RNA derived from Whole blood and
we tested for the insertion of this
pseudo-exon
and as you can see in the graph below
in the control we were only able to pick
up a fragment of 485 base pairs in size
but in the two individuals on the right
or all indicated as lynch-like we could
identify a fragment of 673 base pairs
indicative of a pseudo axon inclusion
we also performed expression analysis of
msh2 in one of these individuals
and comparative controls we saw that
there was indeed a reduced
uh
expression of msh2 which we could Rescue
by adding cyclohexamide which is an
indication that at least one of the two
alleles undergoes a nonsense medial
decay
We performed segregation analysis in
this family and all family members that
were available for just genetic testing
presented with this germline pathogenic
variant in msh2
and this solves basically this family
and now from being a lynch-like family
with unexplained mismatch to repair
deficiency they fall into the category
of Lynch syndrome which means that we
can provide them optimized surveillance
and also targeted mutation analysis in
any family members they may that may
want to get tested
however not for all the variants that we
identified we had access to either
material from
from the individuals to perform
mRNA analysis
or segregation analysis
and for those we perform functional
analysis by the use of mini Gene splice
essays
and in principle we mimic the both the
wild type and the mutant variants
in plasmids that contain the row axons
so basically our Gene region of interest
from Wild type is cloned in one vector
and subsequently in another Vector are
mutants region of interest is clones
we then transfect cells
and we perform
C DNA analysis
and if the mutation has an effect on
splicing for instance introducing a
pseudo axon or Exon skipping we would
see a different
um we would would see this in on an
electrophoresis gel as a difference in
size
and after sequencing we can pinpoint
exactly if there is a spliceite defect
so for each of our variants we perform
this analysis and I give you the example
here of one of the variants in intron 3
of mlh1
and as you can appreciate in this
picture we observed a larger
band in the mutant constructs versus the
wild type constructs and after
sequencing of these bands we observed a
inclusion of a pseudo axon in this case
together we observed that in five of our
variants we a pseudo axon was included
or an X12 were skipped we could observe
altered splicing
meaning that
in um
six of our cases
we identified that these non-coding
aberrations functionally showed an
effect in our mini Gene and promoter
essay
in four of the cases with an mlh sorry
with an msh 2 variants we saw that this
led to pseudo inclusion or premature
stop
or Exxon skipping
and in two out of the three individuals
with an mlh1 variants we observed
altered splicing and a premature
stop-godon
prop Studio excellent inclusion and a
premature stop
two variants remain a variance of
unknown significance as we were unable
to determine whether these are really
pathogenic
and for the other ones our results
pinpoint that they are likely not
pathogenic
so in summary the majority of
individuals with unexplained mismatch
repair deficiency also called lynch-like
have somatic inactivation of one of the
mismatch repair genes
a substantial proportion of individuals
with lynch-like syndrome approximately
90 percent can be diagnosed with Lynch
syndrome because of a germline
non-coding pathogenic aberration in a
mismetric barging
we think that Diagnostics management
repair Gene panels should be expanded
for known intronic pathogenic variants
to increase the diagnostic yield for
Lin's syndrome
however for those cases that remain
without a genetic diagnosis and in our
case we still have 80 percent of them to
solve
we think that cases that after both
germline and somatic routine diagnostic
analysis it remains of interest to
perform germline sequencing of the
complete mismatch repair Gene loans eye
for instance using long read sequencing
approaches also in a in a genome-wide
context
also with our targeted approach we have
probably not been able to identify every
variant in these mismatch repair genes
and hopefully in the new in the near
future
we can identify new variants
foreign
I would like to acknowledge specifically
Lisa Elsa and Eagles to Bosco who has
done who have done most of the work that
I've presented here but also my
collaboration with nicolin murieline
shella and Aryan has been of high
importance for these studies and all
other people listed here to provide
samples and useful discussions and our
funders thank you very much I would be
very happy to answer any questions that
you may have and you may put them in the
Q a box and I'll be happy to provide an
answer thank you very much